[Music]
hi everyone wakey at the life of your
code demo and I'm joined here by Grisha
how are you good how are you good thank
you tell us a little bit about what you
do and what you've made awesome so I'm
alie product marketing here in Google
cloud for our service products and we
recently announced a product called
cloud run today and I'm really excited
about that all right can you show us
what it does super so I'm just going to
build a simple app and we're gonna get
started here so what we're doing right
now is think of the train as the app
itself so we are going to start by sort
of customizing it first and building our
train so building the app so adding a
different different components like
compute database and so on to the train
building the Train so it's checking for
security vulnerabilities and all of
those in the second step and then
finally we are going to deploy it and we
will be able to see it in the big screen
awesome let's get started
super so getting started here adding a
train car first so the first thing that
we're going to add is the engine itself
so engine here is the compute platform
so let's start with the compute so cloud
run is amazing because it enables the
developer to choose to write apps in any
language they choose so for example with
no js' or c-sharp python other options
we have here but really any language a
they can choose to write their apps on
and it's totally fine so I'm just going
to select a blue color here and then
getting started so now that's our engine
so we're going to add a second train car
here so what we really did was just
selecting a language and each language
has a docker file that goes with it so
as a developer what they're doing is
they're writing code in any language
they choose and then the docker file is
what they specify as the developer if I
if I'm a Java developer for example and
the cloud vendor doesn't support Java
that's totally fine I can
to fight the dockerfile and it's going
to package my app into the into a
container and it's going to deploy it so
that's what we're seeing here so I'm
gonna select go let's do this colorful
yeah yeah that looks cool
polka dots and so finally now what we're
going to do is add a database to it so
this is a database that I'm gonna add
because databases are an essential
component of building an app so there
are different options that you can add
if you want to integrate it with cloud
run so we have a few options here like
MongoDB or Redis or Postgres really it
works with any of our Google cloud
offerings as well and so you can a lot
of options to choose from so let's
select one of these a green color let's
go ahead alright so we've completed the
build yeah so now what we have here is
this is the app so think of it as a
developer writing code for the entire
app and they're ready to go as the
developer this is all you will have to
do right which is cold to what they're
doing they don't have to worry about you
know the infrastructure scaling it up
and down monitoring it managing it all
of that is gone away practice on the
courage just the code just focus on the
code and now it's we're going to
complete the build so for this
particular showcase it's using cloud
build underneath it to build a container
image so that's what is happening right
now it's pushing the code to cloud run
so it's checking for security
vulnerabilities it's making sure the the
build image the container image is being
created so now you can see the scale the
scanning the security scanning for the
code as well using cloud build and now
all of this is complete we're going to
give it a name this your initials
J
great tada
yeah so now we are going to just deploy
it this is the exciting part so the
Train is actually going to be seen on
the large screen in just about a second
now awesome oh there it goes that's that
the fun train so now what it's doing is
it's going through the train station of
the QPS there that it's getting a ton of
traffic so think of your app as a lot of
users using your app so it's getting a
lot of traffic and cloud run will
automatically scale your app from zero
literally if there's no traffic to one
of our instance it needs and then bring
it back down to zero all in just within
seconds wow that was a really great
demonstration thank you so much for
joining us thank you for having me
[Music]
you
[Music]